>> [Speaks Foreign Language]
>> What is PubSubHubbub?
>> Slatkin: Hey, I'm Brett Slatkin.
>> Fitzpatrick: I'm Brad Fitzpatrick
>> Slatkin: And we're today to tell you about
a project called PubSubHubbub.
>> Fitzpatrick: It's kind of a dorky name
but it's really a fun, simple, and useful
technology. We often just call it Hubbub for
short.
>> Slatkin: So what does it do? Well, it's
an open protocol for training Atom and RSS
feeds in the real time streams.
>> Fitzpatrick: That sounds a little dorky,
so why don't you consider this contrived to
metaphor instead. Let say you're going on
a long road trip and the people in the backseat
are asking, "Are we there, yet? Are we there
yet? Are we there yet?"
>> Slatkin: No, not yet.
>> Fitzpatrick: As lame as that is. That's
actually how Internet Servers talk to each
other nowadays. They say, "Do you have anything
new for me? Do you have anything new for me?"
>> Slatkin: That's called "pulling" and although
it works, it's slow and inefficient and about
as annoying as a person at the backseat, asking
you.
>> Fitzpatrick: Are we there yet? Are we there
yet? Are we there yet? The alternative is
called "push". It's when the origin publishers
actually tell all the interested subscribers
when there actually is something new.
>> Slatkin: Let's see that in action. On the
right is a microblog that serving an Atom
feed. Here, you can see the entries in a link
that declares that this speed is real-time.
On the left is a Web application with an Ajax
connection to the server. Let me post the
new update. And, look, there it is, it's received
by this other Web application within a second.
These are two completely separate sizes communicating
in real-time through a hub.
>> Fitzpatrick: Consider you're a publisher
and you're writing in your journal. Naturally,
people are interested in what you're writing
and they want to know when you have new content.
To find out about it, they need to keep asking
you if there's something new because that's
the only way they can get updates. This can
be a considerable distraction, wasting time
and effort. What if there were a better way?
Instead, what if subscribers registered their
interest so publishers could tell them when
something is new. When I have something new,
I could immediately send subscribers my updates.
That way, the subscribers don't have to be
so annoying asking so often. Unfortunately,
this is still complicated, and not all publishers
would want to do these themselves, juggling
the separate tasks of publishing and distributing
content. So even better, all publishers can
have an assistant they delegate to. Here,
I have Brett, my faithful assistant. I'll
have him take care of my bookkeeping. He'll
keep track of my current fans and get them
new contents, so I can just write in peace.
When I have something new, I'll only give
it to him and he can distribute it to everyone
else. In PubSubHubbub terminology, Brett,
my assistant is what we call a hub. So, we
hope you enjoyed our cheesy demo, and we hope
you'll check out PubSubHubbub yourself.
>> Slatkin: You can start publishing and subscribing
to real-time feeds using the protocol today.
So give it a try. There are also plug-ins
for many CMSs out there and more on the way.
>> Fitzpatrick: And while this works for feeds
now, imagine the future when this works for
any content-type on the Web, yet, images,
video, or all HTML pages. Let's make the whole
Web real-time.